is it true that your daughter um talked
you into doing career day at her school
is that true that is true uh you know i
was intimidating yeah it's one of those
things where you're and i'm sure that
you've dealt with things like this but
you don't like i want my daughter to
have a really normal you know life with
school i don't want people to to look at
her differently because her dad is who
her dad is but
so she came home and asked me to to come
to a career day
which i'm already i'm an introvert i
really don't go out very often
and the thought of that actually gave me
crazy anxiety to go to a school of kids
and be like hello i'm dan from imagine
dragons like radioactive like for me i
was like
oh my gosh um but on the same note i was
not going to say no because i because of
what i do so i said yeah i thought about
it and i said yeah yeah i'll come do
this and uh
and when i went and met the kids it was
really cool because
kids love imagine dragons they come to
like shows of imagine dragons really
range it's like family affairs yeah um
so i went and of course like the first
question was like can you sing this song
acapella it was which is like everything
i hate to do but so it's the kids so i
did it
you're having a full-on panic attack i
really was i really was but uh but after
me was that a guy walked in from nasa
and so all the kids were like
who cares get out of here imagine
driving a guy he's he's going to get the
rocket ship so i was like okay this
worked out that was cool that's so funny
i wouldn't have pegged you as even like
first when we first talked like after
your show you're such an extrovert to me
i am on stage i feel really free on
stage uh but i really like when it comes
to everything outside of that i yeah
i've had the same like two friends since
i was you know 12 years old and
i never i never really go out uh much so
that's why you know shaq is my friend
since i've been 2012 he's one of my two
friends so he is one of the two it's the
only reason i came on today
i knew that my friend would be here
[Music]
you